I think in our society the last taboo is
money I've gotten used to telling people
you know in 2014 I made less than
minimum wage our taxable income was less
than $23,000 and I was working like
crazy I don't remember exactly how or
who told me about the Dave Ramsey show
but the show has been great for me to
you know stay on the straight and narrow
path everything in our society seems to
be pitched at spending more and being
okay with being in debt I think the last
recession showed many Americans how big
of a lie that is whenever people have
asked me about financial issues I have
recommended the Total Money Makeover for
them and it's a template that can be
used by basically anybody no matter what
their situation is the principles are
foundational I'm a board-certified
otolaryngologist head and neck surgeon
and what that means is I'm an ear nose
and throat doctor when I decided to go
into solo practice in 1992 I took out an
SBA loan it was a line of credit for up
to one hundred and twenty thousand
dollars I only used fifty three thousand
dollars but Bank of America basically
calculated my payment as if I had taken
out the full amount we're going to be
done with a loan and about a third of
the time that we should be but in the
meantime it's killing them while in the
end it turned out to be a huge blessing
for us because it meant that we paid off
fifty three thousand dollars in about
two and a half years we were so addicted
to getting out of debt that we just
wanted to continue that and so we aimed
our guns at the mortgage and discharged
two hundred and seventy four thousand
dollars over the next six years
health plans they just don't pay for
services that are rendered you're
basically paying thousands of dollars
every month to see patients
that's not exactly a profession and so
at the end of 2014 my practice finally
went under and that was a devastating
time for my family of me
it was very humiliating actually because
you know when patients care about a
doctor going on to her they assume that
I must not be a very good doctor I took
a job on a Navajo Reservation in the
remote desert of New Mexico and I was
the only ear nose and throat doctor for
80,000 people we obviously started to
use our emergency funds to maintain our
living expenses and I said to my wife we
can't do this forever without going into
debt because there was no way I was
going to go back into a life of bed
again nine months into my time on the
reservation I was offered a job at
gradle Medical Group in Escondido where
I currently work so I see adults and
children with ear nose and throat
problems there now I have a wife Patti
she and I have been married for 29 years
and then we have three adult children 26
24 and 21 years of age no grandchildren
that we know of ever do it I was willing
to do whatever it took to keep us out of
bed and to maintain the principles that
we had always lived by our kids I think
they heard me rail on them about you
know keeping expenses to a minimum and
trying to save money wherever we could
but when I finally closed the office and
picked up and moved to the reservation I
think they thought hmm looks like he
wasn't kidding
up until that point they really didn't
see anything different happening in
their lives but now with their dad esra
miles away in a tiny apartment just off
the Navajo reservation suddenly they did
the storms are going to come but they're
not going to kill you and you will get
through this I'm happy to tell people
because I think it's the valuable thing
because we have no debt we didn't lose
our home and we didn't lose our cars and
although it was a great loss and very
humiliating for me to lose my practice I
still had our home to come back to I
remember growing up my my father showed
me a letter that came in the mail one
day he was completely done with the
mortgage after I started my practice I
realized what kind of achievement that
was and what kind of peace of mind that
had brought to him I've never asked my
dad directly what do you think about
what's gone on these last years I know
he's proud of me and and that means a
great deal
[Music]
you